let me formally announce to you that the  Eurogroup has a new president Pascale  Donna you I have no doubt that Pascale  will make an excellent president of the  Eurogroup and will certainly wish him  every success in his post I'd like to  send the other two candidates for their  initiative and commitment to the work  our Mirabeau as I begin my tenure as  president of the Eurogroup I'm deeply  conscious does the citizens of Europe  are looking up where their national  economies now stands are looking at the  European economy and have become  concerns have become fearful again for  their futures for their jobs  and further incomes and as great as the  challenges are I'm absolutely confident  that with my colleagues in the Euro  group with our governments we have the  ability and we have laid the foundations  to overcome these challenges and to  prevail  [Music]